Клас!
[захоплено]
Це мій берег.
Мій пірс.
Я навчилась там плавати і…
У нас там була кав’ярня.
Не кав’ярня, а кафешка така маленька.
Маленька кафешка – там ми собі працювали,
заробляли гроші на навчання.
Я там мила посуд,
нарізала салати.
Батько робив плов або шашлик.
У такі, добрі дні була форель на грилі,
у погані дні був тільки плов і шашлик з баранини.
Мама робила манти і приносила на берег.
Ми продавали порційно: десь п'ять-шість штук
у порції.
Так за день було достатньо людей,
які просто приходили пообідати.
На вечерю менше залишалось,
тому що в нас не було спиртного,
і тому ми працювали, в основному, вдень.
Так...
Ух ти! Ух ти, ух ти!
Ух ти, ух ти, ух ти!
Ах!
[дуже захоплено]
Це музична школа?
[здивовано]
Це зараз моя музична школа така?
Нічого собі!
Вау!
[захоплено]
Вона зараз рожева, була більше схожа…
Це старовинний кримськотатарський дім,
який був кам’яним повністю.
На мій погляд, він виглядає як санаторій зараз.
[сміється]
А виглядав як музична школа.
Така старовинна.
Я навчалась на другому поверсі.
Так... Летимо, летимо.
Виноград! Клас! Страшно! Дуже високо! Аааааа!
[піднесено]
Круто!
Ах!
[захоплено]
Боже, як гарно!
Клас!
Виноград, виноград...
Так, так, десь тут, десь тут я…
У мене було суперзавдання після школи:
я мала пасти баранів.
Ну, було небагато їх: десь п'ять-шість максимум.
І після школи десь о другій чи о третій годині я випасала їх у цьому місці.
І мені було так зручно, що я могла їх залишити так собі і...
От десь тут! [несподівано]
От десь тут, так…
Я могла залишити їх, сісти собі там під деревом і співати.
А тут поряд біля мене тільки гори і така була акустика супер, що мені подобалось…
Цей саунд, коли дійсно мені повертались ці вібрації.
Мій голос збільшувався.
І я співала собі якісь свої пісні…
Не пам’ятаю, які…
На жаль, у мене не було диктофону, щоб записати.
А це мій сад, мого qartbaba [дідуся].
Дідусевий сад, який він сам собі посадив.
Інжир, який дає врожай двічі на рік.
О, мій батько збирає… Мій батько збирає інжир,
відвозить на ринок у Сімферополі.
Десь двічі [на рік] інжир дає [врожай].
Ну, сезон наприкінці літа і на початку осені.
На це й живуть.
Він здає цей інжир.
До речі, він користується популярністю.
[сміється]
Кажуть, що його інжир – особливий інжир.
Ну, не знаю, як…
Як це правда чи ні.
Я люблю наш інжир, він особливий,
тому що він зібраний з любов’ю.
Батько нікому не довіряє.
Ми давно йому кажемо –
у нього і спина, і ноги вже болять, і все таке.
Ми кажемо: «Ну, візьми когось,
щоб допомогти тобі з інжиром!»
Він тільки сам збирає – кожну інжиринку вкладає в ящичок.
Боже, клас! Клас, клас, клас, клас, клас! Аааа! От інжир! От! Клас!
[з надзвичайним захопленням у голосі]
Супер!
Побувала вдома.
Шкода, що зараз немає можливості поїхати,
але там дуже класно, дуже красиво. Дуже красиво.
Дякую.